maybe you have heard about the new trend
in terrible parenting it's called babies
this is the label that certain white
upper-class liberal parents have given
to their to their children who they want
to raise gender-neutral they want
gender-neutral children without gender
labels they said down with labels no
more labels and then they proceeded to
invent a new label which is they beasts
so no we don't we don't want any labels
whatsoever except for these over here
that we've just invented off the top of
our head there's an NBC article about
this trend and it's gotten some
attention
it focuses especially on the stories of
Nate and Julia sharp who are well
actually let me just I'll read a little
bit from this article just to cut just
you understand what we're dealing with
here and to kind of set the stage a
little bit let me read from this article
in NBC it says three-year-old twins
xyler and Kayden
scurried around the boy and girls
clothing racks of a narrow consignment
store filled with toys xyler wearing
rainbow leggings scrutinized a pair of
hot pink and purple sneakers Zaidan in a
t-rex shirt fixated on a musical cube
that flashed colourful lights at a
glance the only discernible difference
between these fraternal twins is their
hair sylars is brown and Cadence's
blonde is Ayler a boy or a girl how
about Kayden that's a question their
parents Nate and Julia Sharpe say only
the twins can decide the couple from
Cambridge Massachusetts of course
represent a small group of parents
raising babies children being brought up
without gender designation from birth
Nate Nate sharp told NBC News a baby is
I think different things to different
people for us it means raising our kids
with with with gender-neutral pronouns
so they then their rather than assigning
he/she him/her from birth based on their
Anatomy
let's pause right there for just a
moment okay I don't mean to interrupt
mr. Nate sharp but they they're them
those are pronouns that you have
assigned so you're saying well we're not
going to assign he or she so instead
we're going to assign assigned a in them
you still assigned pronouns you nitwit
it's exactly what you're doing you're
just assigned different pronouns and
actually he and she are not assigned by
anyone any more than your biological sex
is assigned this whole idea of assigned
sex what hit me the site where is sex
where is that happening it's okay it's
not like you've got a bunch of ambiguous
neutral babies being born and then
they're all laying out a nursery then
you've got doctors that come by and go
we're gonna sign him boy make that one a
girl I would have do two girls over
there we'll do that one a boy tonight
you're actually not well let's make that
one a girl that one a boy and all right
so then we got two girl that's not
what's happening but that is not there's
no there's no sex assignment Ward in in
the birthing center of the hospital it
doesn't see what happens is you've got
boys and girls who are born and then the
doctors will look at them and say oh
that's a boy or oh that's a girl and
then linguistically there are certain
pronouns that come attached to that
naturally as part of our language
it's not a sign what you're doing here
Nate sharp is you are actually assigning
artificially a pronoun that that would
not otherwise that that is not natural
to the to the child going back to the
article parents in the US are
increasingly raising children outside
traditional gender norms allowing boys
and girls to play with the same toys
let's wait sorry just wanna stop there
again for sight I love it how these
enlightened liberal parents they think
they're the only ones to ever to ever
dream up this idea of allowing boys and
girls to play with the same toys like
what do they think what do they think
the rest of us are doing do they think
that we if our if our you know if you're
if your son picks up one of his one of
your daughter's toys if your daughter
picks up a one of your son's toys do
they think that you're going hey put
that down no no put it drop it drop it
right there drop it drop it son or
you'll take your turn into a girl put it
down
is that what they thinks happening no
because kids playing with all the same
toys that happens in every house in
America that has always happened it's a
totally normal thing so you didn't come
up with that concept see most of us
normal folks normal parents we have
always been fine with our with our kids
play basically playing with whatever toy
they wanted to play with but we never
made that never caused any confusion for
us we never if we had seen our daughter
pick up a Tonka truck we would say oh
our daughters playing with a Tonka truck
that's fine we didn't then say she must
be a boy no we didn't do that we just
said oh that's a girl who likes Tonka
trucks and then we continued on with our
life um actually I won't go back to the
article anyway you get to the point you
get the point there is one other detail
in this article that I should mention
that they are so Nate and Julia should
part of this Davies thing is that the
parents hide the biological sex from not
only from society but they hide it from
the kids themselves they don't tell the
kids what they are
so they the kids are aware of their own
body parts obviously but they have not
been told what those parts mean
they don't know their own identities
Nate and Julia are keeping that secret
under lock and key until the pay until
the kids get to the point where Nick and
Julia have decided they're old enough to
decide their own gender which I think as
most of these parents will say around
four or five is we're gonna can decide
their own gender so at the age of four
they're still not old enough to make a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich by
themselves they probably don't know how
to tie their shoes there's certainly not
old enough to stay home alone by
themselves they can't drive a car they
can't vote they can't they can't do
anything for themselves at all I mean
they can probably barely even manage to
get their shirts on in the morning
without without without help from their
parents yet we're going to give them
this enormous power to us to come up
with their own genders right that makes
a lot of sense now of course we run into
some logical problems here
there are a lot of logical problems but
let's just focus on a few of them
if and we talked about this in on a show
last week I forget in what context but
let's go back to it for just a second
if if biological sex is meaningless
and gender is just a social construct
then what does it mean to say that
someone is choosing a gender what does
that mean
what are you choosing gender is art we
all agree that you cannot choose sex I
hope we agree with that
biological sex cannot be chosen but you
can choose gender yet you're saying that
gender is an arbitrary invented thing so
what does it mean to choose it what do
you talk what exactly are you choosing
what's the meaning of choosing this
meaningless thing
and on what basis is the choice being
made so if a boy chooses to be a girl
based on his affinity for girly things
because in every case I've ever heard of
when you hear these parents who say oh
yeah he was born biological boy but he's
my daughter now and then they start to
tell their stories the reason that they
give or the the indications that they
give for oh this is when we realized
that he was a girl it always involves oh
he liked to put on dresses or he liked
to play with Barbie dolls every single
time that's what it is it's it's it is
they discovered in their son in affinity
for traditionally girly things so if if
you decide or your child decides that
he's a girl based on his affinity for
girly things have you not just
reinforced the very very societal
construct that you're supposedly trying
to abolish
and if the child makes the decision that
he's a girl based on nothing based not
even on an affinity for girly things
then hasn't the word girl lost all
meaning isn't the word girl now just
another word for boy
I think if if someone is going to say oh
I am a girl then they have to be able to
follow that up with a because so I'm a
girl
because fill in a blank right and if you
can't fill in the blank with the because
then I'm a girl means absolutely nothing
but if you can fill it in with some kind
of because some kind of reason then the
word girl has to have some kind of
meaning but if the word girl and the
word boy do have meaning then the choice
must be based on something objective and
meaningful you can't have it both ways
and if it's based on something objective
and meaningful then gender is not a
societal construct it is in fact
something ingrained you see what you see
what I'm saying here there's a this
doesn't make any sense at all no sense
also another problem if you haven't told
your children anything about boy and
girl
and they haven't learned to associate
those words with anything in particular
then what in the world does it mean for
them to choose between the two they
don't even know what that is so let's so
little Zeiler a poor kid has no concept
of boy and girl at all he's none he
doesn't have any idea what those things
mean and then at the age of four the
parents gonna go to them and say what
are you a boy or a girl
and he's gonna say whatever he says what
it means nothing he may as well go up to
him and say um hey Zeiler what are you a
gobbledygook or a blue buddy blah but
which one oh he says he's a blue pony
blah that's his identity his identity is
blue pony blah everyone respected
this is the is his is his natural
identity he's discovered it
but these are I could go on for four
hours with the logical fallacies here
but the real problem is not one of logic
it's one of just basic ethics and
morality
this is there's a there's a very serious
morale problem here where Nate and Julia
to show off to their liberal friends
have deprived their children of identity
and I really do believe this is I would
like to say for their benefit to be
generous to Nate and Julia I would like
to say that these that that they are
just crazy insane people who are not
intellectually capable of understanding
the logical contradictions that I have
just outlined but no apparently they are
Mechanical Engineers upper-class
mechanical engineers these are people
with brains in their heads and they must
possess the ability to understand logic
and understand how ideas and things all
fit together
so they must be smart enough to
understand that this whole thing makes
no sense whatsoever they're just trying
to show off it's for their own sake it's
selfishness these parents that do this
it is total selfishness
and that's all it is they are using
their kids as like these fashion
statements and they're saying to all
their friends aren't we so fashionable
we have gender-neutral children we're so
fashionable yeah you're very fashionable
and the price of you making a fashion
statement is that you are destroying and
ruining your kids on an elemental level
like you're getting right down to the
core of who your kids are and just
obliterating it that's what you're doing
you're not freeing them from artificial
cultural influences by raising them
neutrally rather you are overriding
those influences by imposing a much more
artificial much more confusing and much
more damaging one
so it is eat look it's easy to kind of
laugh at something like babies and to
laugh at these parents but there's
something it's not really funny what's
happening here
this is psychological child abuse of the
most demented kind this is deranged
they're robbing their children of
identity they're robbing their children
of even the most basic knowledge of
their own cells knowledge that they need
in order to decide what they want to do
and who they want to be and where they
want to go in life they're taking that
away from them you may as well refuse to
till you tell your children what species
they belong to or what planet they live
on this is just the most basic
information about their about themselves
about their relation to the world about
their place in the order of things the
most basic information like the kind of
information that that non abusive
parents will start with like this is 24
normal non abusive parents one of the
first things your kid learns about
himself is his sex one of the first
things he learns is I'm a boy or I'm a
girl
it's just basic information that you
need about who you are and these parents
are taking that from their kids this is
a social experiment like what if we
raise kids through the first part of
their formative years without telling
them anything about themselves
whatsoever what will happen then
they're gonna just sit back and see well
let's see what happens
nothing good I could tell you that the
thing is you could have especially in
low-income areas what this is what
really infuriates me particularly in
low-income areas you could have Child
Protective Services knocking on your
door if you so much as spank your
children if somebody hears of you
spanking your kid or if you yell at your
kid in public or something like that you
could have CPS knocking on your door yet
these people are turning their kids into
social experience experiments they are
hiding essential biological truths from
their children they're depriving their
children of identity they are force
feeding mental illness into their kids
and rather than a visit from CPS they're
going to get a profile on NBC
it is really unthinkable and awful and
just disgusting
it's child abuse and that's what we need
to call it
I think we need to be we need to start
putting our foot down about this kind of
stuff
you and I as normal human beings
we need to put our foot down and say
it's not just like oh we disagree with
that
parenting style it's know you are
ruining your kids you are abusive you
are unfit parents what you're doing to
your children is unthinkable and evil
and it should be illegal that's what
that's what this should be this is the
worst kind of psychological abuse I have
ever heard of that's how bad it is and
that's what we need to start saying now
I'm gonna switch gears here so that's so
I've said all I can say about that I'm
sure we'll revisit again in the future
if you listen to the show you know that
I will sometimes deviate from the topic
and get into entirely irrelevant
rants about subjects that frankly aren't
even interesting and usually I do that
at the very beginning of the show I have
decided to move it to the end and so
this will be a new segment that I call
random things I'm talking about
I need to think of a name for it but
anyway that's what we'll put that on the
back burn all right here's the thing we
need to talk about elevators I was there
are some basic things about elevators
that I think everyone and I thought
everyone in society understands but
apparently they don't I was traveling
last week I was staying at a at a hotel
and I had a pretty horrific experience
on an elevator here's what happened I
boarded the elevator in the lobby and
then another person also boarder boarded
and that's not the horrific experience
although that obviously is pretty
horrific in and of itself and so the
elevator starts going and this guy's a
small talker I'm not a small talk I'd be
fine just standing in stone silence and
saying nothing but this guy's a small
talker so right away he says I gets on
and he says man it's hot outside
and I say yeah
yeah it is hot you know it's really hot
I'm like I'm sweating hot
I'm not very good at small talk up you
can tell and he says well you know the
calling for rain all next week so it
should cool down with the rain and I
said oh really
okay
and then silence okay I had I had I had
killed the small talk conversation
inadvertently which is what I always do
so the small talk died and then that's
the problem because if you're going to
open the small talk valve you kind of
have to keep it going because if you
don't if you initiate the small talk but
then you're still with that person for
awhile after the small talk has died
well now the silence has become about
ten times more awkward than it would
have been if you had just never said
anything whatsoever so the problem is
small talk died at about the third or
fourth floor
we still had ten more floors to go and
then we get to the tenth floor we get
off on the same floor and we walk the
same direction down the same hallway
after all of that weird silence and
after the conversation had died so it
was just if we the conversation died ten
more floors of silence we get off and we
walk silently next to each other down
the hallway to our rooms and it just
made me think this awkwardness could
have been avoided if everyone had just
observed elevator rules and these are
rules that when I am dictator of America
I will in state upon penalty of death
and there are two rules okay it's very
simple the first rule is this no talking
in an elevator whatsoever no eye contact
no looking at anyone you can look up at
the ceiling or you can look down at the
floor you don't look you don't talk
complete silence and this is the rule so
there's no reason for the sounds to be
awkward because it's a rule now you have
to be sign and if you don't you'll be
killed or you know maybe you'll go to
prison for ten you will figure that out
second rule the company who owns the
elevator
must have elevator music whatever
happened to elevator music I mean it
used to be you get an elderly elevator
there's me know there's music now
there's no music it's just silent there
must be elevated music and it must be
loud and blaring so as to alleviate the
awkwardness of the silence and even to
rule out the possibility of silence I
also think the same requirements should
be should be instated in public
restrooms those are the two places no
talking
loud music all problems solved
all right now that we have that
established I've just solved the
elevator problem and I've solved the
gender-neutral problem so we've solved
two problems I think that's pretty
productive thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed